welcome back to Long crime daily an Ohio
woman appeared in court on Thursday
after being charged with killing her 16
month old daughter in June Jalen
candelario was found unresponsive in a
playpen inside her Cleveland home
according to police the child appeared
to be extremely dehydrated and the
playpen was soiled with urine and feces
the girl's mother 31 year old Christa
candelario admitted to authorities that
she left Jalen under tenant for 10 days
while she vacationed in Puerto Rico and
Detroit neighbors told reporters that
the mother had asked them to watch her
child in the past but hadn't asked this
time around Crystal was arrested and
charged with murder felonious assault
and child endangerment prosecutors have
also reserved the right to seek the
death penalty crystal is jailed on one
million dollars bond in Thursday's
hearing the defendant psychiatric
evaluation was addressed by the judge
the forensic psychologist assigned to
the case let the court know that she
will complete it by Labor Day the report
will be Revisited after another hearing
scheduled for September 12th
Bernardo what type of Defense could this
mother possibly use she went on vacation
for weeks and left her 16 month old what
could she possibly say
well her defense attorneys are working
on that defense by requesting a
psychiatric evaluation so depending on
the results of that psychiatric
evaluation I would be curious to see
whether the defense attorney is going to
claim that she's not guilty by reason of
insanity or some other type of mental
defect so we'll just have to wait on
that report to see where this case is
going but if the psychiatric evaluation
says that she's all clear then her best
bet is try to go for that the
prosecution can't prove that case Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt but that's going to
be very difficult I see a plea going
down in this case if they can't get the
mental defect right I absolutely agree
with you I mean you know it's over a
week 10 days I think you know you have
to know better than that no matter what
your mental state might be Judge Rucker
one million dollars it's a large amount
of money but should Bond have ever been
set at all in this case
well it's not unusual at all for a
million dollar bond to be set and we
hear of uh cases involving allegations
of murder in Ohio bond is required
except in capital cases certainly uh
Bond here could have been waived
um but sometimes it's for the dramatic
and the public effect of having such a
high Bond uh to to impart on the
seriousness of the offense as well right
I mean I can't even possibly imagine
that she would be let out pending trials
and it is a high amount and maybe they
were trying to send a message saying you
know look she's never going to make this
and so that's why we're setting it this
high but it's a very serious crime and
it should be obviously taken very
seriously well when we come back the
ex-wife of a Microsoft executive is
arrested and ultimately charged with his
murder police now sharing footage of
Shanna Gardner's arrest right in front
of the couple's children that's next
[Music]
we're finishing Today's Show with a
story that crisscrosses the country 36
year old Shayna Gardner Fernandez has
been charged in the murder of her
ex-husband Microsoft executive Jared
bride again in Jacksonville Beach
Florida we're now seeing footage from
the day of Gardener's arrest in
Washington state right in front of the
couple's children
you have orders on your on the Instagram
that is managing for you you have orders
we just uh have Grandma help you get
into what are your jeans mom
um
it's gonna be the white vehicle back
there I'll go to that passenger side
I'll get you down to jail
um
soon as possible and then we'll get you
out of these houses yeah
um probably about 10 15 minutes 10
minutes plus construction so that's not
bad do you want me to grab this and put
it in the trash no no we'll get it for
you that's all right
police say Jared bride again dropped off
the couple's twins at Gardner's home in
Florida and headed to his own home with
his two-year-old daughter on the ride
back bride again came across a tire in
the road and when he got out to move it
police say he was shot and killed here's
where the story gets tricky the man who
confessed to shooting bride again was
Henry Tenon he lived in a property owned
by shayna's current husband Mariel
Fernandez while authorities were left to
connect the dots Shayna distanced
herself from Fernandez and moved across
the country to Washington that's where
she was ultimately arrested and charged
last week with murder conspiracy and
child endangerment prosecutors intend to
seek the death penalty against Gardner
and Fernandez who was arrested back in
March Gardner intends to fight her
extradition back to Florida in a hearing
on September 14th meanwhile the
suspected trigger man Henry Tennant
continues to cooperate with authorities
Bernardo we've seen all kinds of arrest
and you know in this arrest they had the
guns they had these rifles they did this
in front of the children do you think
that this was appropriate or do you
think that this is the type of crime
where they had to go in blasting or at
least go in with the guns obviously
there was no shooting during this arrest
so when you're talking about officers
going to arrest someone for a homicide
let's think about what is the crime the
highest crime possible most violent
crime and that being homicide so law
enforcement has to take certain
precautions because they're operating
under the allegations that this person
was a part of or if not committed to
homicide directly herself so they're
taking proper precautions so this is
actually normal and what is warranted
because those officers don't know what's
on the other side of that door and
Bernardo just to follow up with that we
knew that there were children inside
what could they have done I mean could
they have taken the children and given
the children to the grandmother and she
did ask about that
yeah so in terms of the kids usually
what happens when either search wine is
executed or an arrest warrant is
executed and they know that there are
kids in the house usually they call ACS
or the equivalent of that to take the
kids or a family member to take the kids
so that way the kids aren't just
remaining in the house they're not going
to be there by themselves because law
enforcement is still responsible for
everyone that is inside of that house
right so Judge Rucker listen we do know
that Gardner Fernandez she was pretty
Cooperative during that entire rest and
she was answering questions and
everybody actually seemed calm including
the children now what I want to know is
does that type of behavior affect
whether or not these individuals will be
released on bond that they cooperated
during the rest that they didn't put up
a fight that they went along with
everything that the police asked them to
do
in the cases I was involved in no it
doesn't it didn't and it shouldn't I
mean we just heard that they go in with
with guns blazing uh I hope that there's
going to be cooperation but what we look
at for bail is the conduct that led to
the arrest the conduct during the course
of the investigation itself and the
person's prior history whether they may
run or what relationship they have to
others and in other places but how they
have acted doing the arrest itself no
that should take no consideration I have
no consideration and bondage sales well
does the judge even get an R opportunity
to know what went on during the rest
they didn't go in with the guns blazing
although I I did say that obviously they
went in with these guns and they had the
guns out but do you get an opportunity
as a judge to hear what exactly went on
during the arrest
if there's something that happens that's
significant during rest like if she did
fight or if she did take off running or
if there were other people in the house
with weapons we'd certainly hear that
but if it's a calm arrest and the person
surrenders normally the defense attorney
says it but it doesn't hold a lot of
sway with the bond itself exactly and
obviously you look at what type of crime
this is so thank you both for being here
and thank you for joining us here on
lawn crime daily we will see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America